makeshift hospitals are one of the
defining images of this epidemic but
this is the original in Beijing built in
seven days to fight the SARS outbreak in
2003 now they are rebuilding it to fight
a new virus one that has killed more
people in China alone than SARS did
worldwide the long painful memory of
SARS has resurfaced in this new epidemic
Beijing was badly affected and so this
city of more than 20 million people
feels deserted again this shopping and
office complex should be packed
so should the underground this is rush
hour for locals the comparison is never
far from mind me them go south and bring
a lawyer we can use mr. Tim Erica she
tell you she's a Matata
[Music]
it wasn't just a lack of news it was a
cover-up as authorities hit the scale of
the epidemic SARS short for severe acute
respiratory syndrome killed 774 people
in eight months this time things are
different the World Health Organization
has said China has been more transparent
and the country is richer with more
resources to fight the epidemic but that
development brings danger too for
example the high-speed rail network that
is a modern wonder is also a new way for
the disease to spread and the country's
default setting is still secrecy this
facility is being built out of site in
Beijing it has tight security bars on
the windows and close surveillance this
picture obtained exclusively by Sky News
shows its extent we learned it's to
isolate migrant workers returning to the
city after the extended New Year's
holidays even this is too sensitive
authorities to show we were spotted by
police they ordered us to delete our
footage China has changed almost
unbelievably since our set in 2002 2003
back then its economy was still smaller
than the UK's so now it has a lot more
money a lot more tools a lot more
technology to draw on but it still
relies on old-school post 1949 communist
methods isolation units like this to try
and combat epidemics
for all the echoes of SARS though this
is very different so the mortality rate
from this coronavirus is estimated at
about two percent the mortality rate
from SARS was approximately ten percent
so it's actually less lethal than SARS
in terms of the likelihood of someone
dying if they become infected but
because it has spread more readily and
proportionately we have a lot more
people who've been infected we see a lot
more deaths there will be more deaths to
come SARS has long cast a shadow in
people's memories now it is in the
shadow of this new epidemic